we got new merch some new colorways uh
in the be good to yourself collection
we've got hoodies in Plum and Moss we've
also got t-shirts in lilac moss and Blue
Mist
I hope you enjoy those those are good
colors
get that hitter and more at
theovenstore.com
that's it
I mean summer is it's a wrap on summer
that's that's done that's done you can't
you still see something I
was on the interstate the other day and
when that some family driving to the
beach and I just you know
in the back seat you could see the kid
with like a little sand pail and
you know and he had like a
little bucket or a little
you know you just tell us all the hope
and possibility in his eyes and then you
just realized damn man his family
taking him to the cold Beach
and that's definitely you know when I
was young we
we had to do the cold Beach you know
because it's certainly
you know rich people don't realize when
they leave the beach
that there's that's you know that other
tier of humanity
that rolls into the beach maybe when
that [ __ ] is cold
because it's cheaper
you get your hotel room 19 in there
31 dollars
all you can sleep
they get you in that bed yeah
everybody's in that [ __ ] you have 7 12
them 19 children in there
in a two-bed in a
Deluxe or something two-bed Deluxe or
something one sink I don't know how they
divide it up nowadays or whatever you
know free ice
and all of that you're at the beach
and I remember man we go down to the
cold Beach and it you know when Mom
tries to act like it's like it's gonna
be it's fine it's warm
and nobody's out there except other poor
just people don't even know how to use
the beach you know
people only don't even know what's going
on people
some guy out there eating sunscreen with
a spoon just
people just you know
that shanby that shan't be even at the
beach
and they out there
people just poor people just building
sand Apartments
you see that with they have the uh and
the kids will make like a sand cop car
and then a say they'll have a sand
father getting put into the cop car
he'll make like damn bro
so you see a lot of when you know when
poor people hit the beach it's a little
bit different
you know a lot more people come out
there with attack dogs you'll see uh you
know somebody out there with a big
attack with a Rottweiler
and that he's out there you know
catching crabs and [ __ ] he's out there
you know
he'll run them Rottweilers are powerful
too
they'll run right it'll run half you
know into the waves and come out with a
just a damn sturgeon in their mouth
you know you send a dang uh
what are those dogs uh Zach that kill
people every year
pitbulls yeah you'll see somebody out
there have a pit bull run out into the
water he'll come back with four Frisbees
and a damn mackerel
and a couple of and his hair cornrow you
see that [ __ ] you know
that's when poor people hit the beach
that's when it's cold
when people don't realize that there's
no sun out there
it's mostly just crabs and uh
a lot of jellyfish
you know a lot of high fructose
jellyfish too
and they out there
but people forget that what it's like
yeah nothing like a um
a cold a trip to the cold Beach
my mother would take us over there to
Biloxi
Mississippi
and then I don't even know if this beach
was incorporated it might have still
been barely a LLC if that
I mean it would they had like
a lot of this the Water by The Edge had
like this froth on it it looked like
um
it looked like uh
there'd been some like um I don't know
if like vomiting or if maybe like fish
have been vomiting over there
it just like they had a
I can't even explain it man the edge of
the water where it hit the shore had
like um
a lot of foam it looked like a top of a
beer that's what it looked like
it looked like a lot of the water was
probably had beer in it
and if you if you grew up along the
coast especially the Gulf of Mexico and
I think even some
I think I think it happens in a lot of
places where the B it gets a little
you know you're like damn this water
looks sick
the water looks like it's not doing well
like you should
you know put a blanket on her I mean I
don't know how you would even do that
but it's like the it just
so anyway we went to the damn poor Beach
and I you know and the vendors there
that they you know the warm weather was
over so you go to the hot dog stand or
whatever and they'd be selling just gum
and you're like gum
[ __ ]
you know you get you nine pieces of gum
the guy would sometimes shape the gums
and you're like a wiener
and put three other gums on the side
make a little Frank you know a little
bread a little
like damn this [ __ ]
taking eight hours to eat that [ __ ]
because you know gum it kind of fights
back a little bit when you try to eat it
if you're just chewing gum it'll work
with you but if you
if you really try to eat it it'll it'll
wanna you know gum don't want all that
you know you know when you swallow gum
that you are not supposed to
gum is you know
it's halfway to Plastic Man
um
but anyway yeah
it's fall time it's what you know this
is where we are this is what's going on
I want to thank everybody who came out
recently
uh we went and did some shows out there
Wichita
Omaha and Denver it was it was wonderful
man Wichita
you know it's a real there's not a lot
going on in the city
so when you see people during the it
almost feels like during the day it's
like uh
it has a very kind of like war-torn Vibe
you know it's not a lot of people
running around
you know it's almost like if you see
someone you ask them you know
you know if everything's okay or if they
need water it's like you know it has
that kind of
you know you you don't and if you see
somebody you almost hug them because you
don't know if you're going to see nobody
again
um but then the shows at night people
flock in
and so I think it's more
I don't know what it is I don't know if
maybe people were
just working out in the yard like in the
what's the yard of a city called
like the suburbs or whatever
like the surround whatever maybe people
are working out there and then they came
through
um but that was great uh Omaha yeah the
Omaha the venue there was it was in like
a dang Orchestra place
and I didn't know that
and so that wasn't really the best
choice for a comedy venue
ah so that was real or real you know
that was a
felt a little ramshackle in that sense
like even right when we pulled up they
had people rolling out with like
Symphony instruments and
you know somebody with a big
you know a big uh harp some dude with a
damn harp it was like damn this dude
he got a damn harp over here you know
and so you know he's probably [ __ ]
um
but uh
but yeah that was you know there was
just a lot of symphony play it was just
it was more built for a symphony so it
was it was just interesting to do comedy
in that room and then
moving over to Denver that was that was
awesome
um so but yeah everybody that came out
man thank you guys so much and and we
actually have some new dates to announce
we're gonna come back to Colorado
um and that will be January 12th
13th 14th and 15th those shows will be
in Grand Junction
Pueblo Pueblo Denver
and Fort Collins
um so you guys can come check all of
those out uh we'll also have shows March
2nd and March 3rd uh and those will be
in Medford Massachusetts and Boston
Massachusetts at the Chevalier
theater and the Wilbur Theater artist
pre-sale starts Wednesday October 19th
at 10 A.M with the code rat king and the
General on sale starts Friday October
21st at 10 A.M local those times are
your local time get your tickets
theophon.com
tour so excited to be rolling back to
some of those places man
um
we also did some shows in Lexington
and man we got to go out to we went out
to a horse farm we met a fella this
fella Dylan I think his name
seemed like a
he was kind of like a um
just a man
you know when you saw him you seemed
like him he seemed like a man you might
ask directions from looked like he had
directions you know what I'm saying like
a reliable source
uh
well anyway so he took us out we met him
at a show and then he took us out to a
horse farm
and we got to ride on a horse and
if you've never been on a horse man them
[ __ ] is a real
it's a I mean
Pat it reminds me I have a when I first
had a power steering vehicle
you know my my dad used to let me drive
his Cutlass he had a Cutlass
and I would drive that [ __ ] and uh
it probably weighed maybe I don't know
how much a car weighs 3 000 pounds or
something
how much does a car weigh Zach can you
pull that up
and uh I mean out in that thing it had
power steering I don't know it didn't
have that much power but
I mean it was hard to steer it was
almost like steering a boat it was I
mean in fact it was horrible and I
remember one time
he went into the post office and I hit a
couple car I took it for a quick span
around the block because my dad was real
old so when he went into the post office
to take him you know 12 18 minutes to
get there and back
you know because he had that slow stride
on him
I mean my dad just walked so slow he had
that age in him
you know he had all the years inside of
him every year you could he was just a
damn [ __ ] stack of calendars with
lungs and heart
and he would get out the car to go walk
somewhere dude you'd have all the time
you could do whatever you wanted
you had all the time in the world
I mean you had half a you know it took
forever for him to come back
so I remember he pulled up at the post
office he'd be like I'm gonna run inside
and I knew that he meant walk
and uh so he get up out the seat and
stuff and I get in the driver's seat and
take that [ __ ] for a lap
that brown Cutlass
and I had some burn marks on the back
somebody tried to steal
my dad had a bunch of M M's and
different things and stuff
that he gave away because he he used to
sign people up for credit cards at
colleges and stuff and
and he was an alcoholic but he he had a
trunk full of M M's one time and
and they had a couple people tried to
get in there and steal them and try to
burn their way in
which was
just dumb you know I think to you know
to try and
just use regular fire to get through a
trunk is just [ __ ] I think and no
offense if anybody's [ __ ] bro
um but anyway what was I talking about
Zach yeah I looked up the average weight
of a car it's around three thousand four
thousand pounds but a Cutlass was very
heavy so I bet it's more closer to four
thousand yeah that [ __ ] was heavy man
but my dad would get up and go walking
man dude he would walk it take a bird
would land on him not even they thought
he was you know stationary he'd be that
just down I mean just barely going you
know you'd see him come he was just
it looked like he they come and build a
fountain around like a build a water
thing and people start throwing pennies
in he just then they'd be like oh damn
this guy's moving you know this is not
sorry my bad sir and uh but he was just
so slow man my dad was so slowing
so anyway he'd go in the bank or the
post office wherever and I'd get in that
Cutlass that driver's seat and I'd take
that [ __ ] for a spin
and one time I took it around the block
and I hit a couple parked cars with that
bastard
why am I hitting them matches Doug and
I prayed for those people afterwards and
you know
so I did my part but uh so anyway back
to the horses so yeah this thing
man being on a horse is really it's not
for
it's not for me I don't think you know
we went out it
it's just that thing you don't know
what's gonna happen
it's like it has a bunch of Gears but
you don't have you don't know them
that's a thing
it's like riding in a car it's like
there's no
like what you have to like
like that's one of the things it's a lot
of secret code
and that thing man it was hard and
you're just bouncing up and down and
you're like dude the whole time like
after like the fifth or sixth bounce
you're like damn dude I think I'm gay
bro it's like
it it just I don't know what the
long-term goal is you know I bet if you
met jockeys when they first started a
male jockeyer and then you met him again
six seven years later bro
I bet he knows a few more men you know
what I'm saying bro
I'm saying animal induced homosexuality
baby
it's happening
um but that was amazing we had a great
time we went out to Keeneland
in Keeneland if you hadn't been there I
thought it was a hospital you know they
said we're going to Keeneland and I was
like oh man you know
I'll get some flowers or whatever but uh
but it's a you know it's where all the
horses go to race or whatever and them
[ __ ] they're out there bro they
you know some of them roll up and
and I'm gonna say this man I mean this
is happening in a lot of sports now like
we they're not even any white horses
left in the [ __ ]
I mean I don't when I don't know if a
white a white horse has even won
about uh
whatever it's called the Belmont or
whatever
I'm just saying like we gotta we gotta
if we're gonna do it we gotta do it you
know if people are doing like if you
need equality in this sport you need
equality in this sport
you know we need a Title IX or Title 11
you know white horses
because they ain't even got a gray
[ __ ] out there winning has a
white horse ever won the uh I'm looking
up Kentucky Derby winners right now so
far last four all brown yeah
and I'm saying you get out there and you
can tell that it's a real you know it's
a brown boys game out there
so I'd love to see a little bit more
diversity out there I'd like to see a
little uh
a little
um
Asian horse out there little
you know oh I'm a horse you know or so
whatever however they would do it
uh pull up Asian horse what do they got
we actually found a golden horse which
is from Turkmenistan yeah dude
that's black that sounds pretty
yeah that oh wow that thing
God
does that thing having only fans that
thing's fine bro
my God
damn oh my God bro
and if that thing came by
and look I've long said this about
animal sex if you have if you have sex
or intimate
with an ant with a house animal or with
a basic animal sheep
um
wool or whatever you know what else is
there sheep cow
uh goat
if you have sex with one of those
animals dude that's
that's nothing anybody could do that and
that's probably a crime but if you mount
this this thing or one of these would if
you mount something Majestic or you know
a bear uh links
uh Minx
um
then that that's a that's not the same
thing you're not going to jail
if I'm a cop or the officer or I'm the
mayor what if you're not going to jail
somebody comes in you're hanging out the
bottom of one of these [ __ ]
I mean you're hanging out the bottom of
a damn mountain lion bro
you're gonna get a high five from me
now if you try to knock it up dude
you're going to jail
you know what I'm saying that's dirty
science bro that's damn spanking Stein
dog you trying to make something nasty
in your apartment
but yeah if you're just doing this man
you win bro if I think if you
if you bang something Majestic and you
caught it on natural terms
I don't see that's and that in my world
that's no crime man that's heroic
uh
but yeah we went out to Keeneland man
that was really great Lexington
unreal City
just a perfect small uh small small City
large town
um but Denver is unreal uh Wichita Omaha
oh nice oh all nice places to be
mint mobile you want to know about mint
mobile
you know people look at their current
Wireless plan and they say well these
are the only options I have
wrong
mint mobile is here it's available they
have premium Wireless for just 15 a
month there's no trapping you into a
two-year contract or you know all the
crazy extra fees oh you got to pay for
this and the lumber or whatever the
lumber
there's no luring you in with
subscriptions to streaming services or
whatever none of that
for if you hate your phone built mint
mobile offers premium Wireless just 15
bucks a month keep your same phone
number along with your existing contacts
get premium Wireless for this 15 bucks a
month and no unexpected plot twists at
mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mintmobile.com Theo
seriously you'll make your wallet very
happy at mintmobile.com
Theo UFC 280. it's here gosh I am
excited
um you and you should be too and you can
get closer to the octagon with
DraftKings sports book the official
sports betting partner of UFC
right now new customers can bet five
dollars on UFC 280 and get two hundred
dollars in free bets if your fighter
wins if you haven't tried DraftKings
sports book today is the day
want even more action you can also
double your winnings on a same game
parlay download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use promo code Theo
throw down five dollars on UFC 280 and
get two hundred dollars in free bets if
your fighter wins that's code Theo this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
dude I was thinking about this about
animals and and humans all right
I think humans
I got this theory that like animals
because animals are on four legs right
they're on four legs so their Earth
they're like really connected with
nature you know humans are kind of the
only species that isn't super connected
with nature
you know we are but we're also kind of
not
and one of the things that I was
thinking about was
because animals they're on the Earth
right their hands touch the Earth and
their legs
right and so the Earth kind of like it
makes a circuit through their body
so you know they're they're
they you know they have a completed
circuit with the Earth and so it's like
everything that the Earth is all the
nature that's inside of the earth and
the elements of nature that goes right
through the animal through its whatever
legs or feet or arms and comes out you
know it's just part of the circle part
of the cycle
and then humans we're standing up
so we're kind of like this loose cable
where it's like you got the energy like
the connection from the earth comes in
but then it starts rattling because it's
not getting out
you know and I think that's one of like
I don't know if that's like if that made
us develop like some of the way that we
think because we have all this weird and
like this energy that doesn't have like
an outlet
um
and I don't even know if this kind of
makes sense but I was part of me was
then thinking what if the energy that
doesn't
because usually if like your part in
nature then you know the energy just
comes up and goes out you right you're
you that connected loop with your
because you're four-legged
but if you're two-legged then the energy
is just going to come in
and not be able to get out
so then I wonder if maybe that's one of
the reasons why we started thinking
about having like gods and stuff like
that because before if the energy went
right back into the Earth and if we just
knew we were part of the same source
you know we knew it was all connected
but if not if it just the energy just
kind of rattles in this cul-de-sac
then it I could see it start to manifest
ideas of like
like gods or higher powers or something
like that because it's not connected to
the source like it's supposed to be
so I don't know if that makes any sense
but I feel like maybe we're supposed to
be on four
limbs
you know that's why I think when you do
yoga and stuff that stuff for you it
makes you feel so keyed in you know
um
yeah and the only uh like some other
animals that are on two legs you have
let me see
kangaroo look at that [ __ ] dog now that
[ __ ] ain't doing well bruh
let's be honest bruh when you see a
kangaroo that [ __ ] ain't doing well
dude they making babies in their pocket
they're fighting each look they got yeah
they're fists fighting they're making
babies in their uh in their ah you know
they're they're uterus is like in a damn
you know they got like a fanny pack
front uterus I don't know what they're
doing there yeah they fight yeah they
got children hiding out their wiener
hole or whatever I mean it doesn't
none of it makes yeah look at them
they're fighting they're beating people
they had a couple of them ran through a
fence somewhere the other day but they I
mean and nothing about the animal looks
like it's doing well either they look
like somebody was trying to do something
and then like the lab got busted
you know they look like some kind of
Frankenstein dude was trying to put some
[ __ ] together
and then the cops rolled up and he was
like ah [ __ ] it I'm out of here and then
that thing just beat through the damn
drywall bro them [ __ ] are gang
bangers son
dude if you were I mean if I I'm sure in
the animal kingdom these are like the
MS-13 of animals these are the Bloods
and the crypts and the whatever you know
I mean these things will pop look at
this I mean here's one right here my God
I mean this one obviously
I mean this this one probably owns a
yacht bro I mean these things are [ __ ]
up
they're in a crypto that's a [ __ ] that's
a kangaroo
I mean this thing is modeling you got to
see some of these videos and get the
picture down there with the Mexican kids
he's trying to fit in with the family to
get out of the country look at this [ __ ]
dude that thing is crazy bro and look at
that wiener and the Mexicans right there
I mean what's going on but yeah anything
that obviously so that's what we are
we're almost like this kangaroo but
we're all it's just mostly in our head
we don't know what's going on because
we're stuck on two legs we're not
completing this this the uh circuit so I
think that's something that could have
happened to humans is at some point
you know whenever we got on two legs it
just
you know that energy gets stuck in our
brain at the end of us so of course it
would make our brain really advanced
and then
since we don't have our life sources
we're not connected back to the Earth
then we would start to create a higher
power we'd have to start to create some
reason
because I think if you're connected to
the Earth you're a four-legged animal
then the reason just flows through you
and you know it
um
so I don't know I was thinking about
that uh
uh you know one thing I realized doing
on tour busing was
um
you gotta really
know when to hold them and know when to
fold them
and I'm talking about defecation
doing number twos BMS
because it's like you know it's outlawed
on a tour bus people don't BM on there
you know if you got to do Duty or you
got to really
if you got something in your body that
ain't pissed that wants to come out then
you got to do that on your own time
um
and yeah it makes sense on there it
makes sense it's a it's like a code it's
almost like a it's like a
what's like a code of conduct
like not Morse code yeah it's like an
etiquette it's like a coat of conduct
like we don't shoot we don't [ __ ] on
here
we don't do it you know it's just like
this thing it's like this Battle Cry
um
and yeah I get you know and some people
have you know a lot of people ride that
you know they're they're really
you know I probably defecate probably
maybe three times a week right
and I've met friends that do it
often probably
you know that are
I think it's kind of taking the easy way
out if you
if you [ __ ] more than twice or three
times a week to me that's
you're not even doing anything
you're just [ __ ]
I mean I think there's a
it's sort of a thing like all right do
you know
how tough am I you know
um
and when I was young it was always like
that
you know my father didn't want to sit
there [ __ ] all the time
you know he'd make us you know just be
outside or say y'all have better things
to be doing
uh it's kind of a weak man's game
you know
um my dad used to say that's when the
enemy gets you
and he's kind of right you know because
when you're in that when you're in a
fecy position that's easily when you can
get attacked
and we had this one fell in our area
this kid Bennett was his name Bennett
and I don't know what it stood for
or if it didn't might not have stood for
anything it could have just been it just
was Bennett
and he had uh
he had this deal where if he had to
you could tell if he had to defecate or
do poop
he's he'd be start getting real quiet
he'd start getting real quiet and you
can almost tell
you know uh until he was almost silent
and you'd have to tell a man go go in
there go do it and a second he was empty
bro he just a chatterbox
it was almost like you couldn't fit
words and poop in him at the same time
you know like he had some sort of
this is yin and yang inside of his body
where there wasn't room enough for all
of it
because you'd catch him after launch and
he'd be a little quieter and then after
dinner if he hadn't gone to the bathroom
if he'd just forgotten to go and he just
fell asleep in the morning he'd just be
almost damn deaf
he'd just be almost a damn mute bro
and you just want to just
I mean you almost just damn go boy go so
we can chat
but yeah Bennett he just man he wouldn't
and people would get on them they'd be
like say something bro say something or
go [ __ ]
one or the other you know
oh Bennett huh
oh sh old silent Bennett
all full of [ __ ] people would say and
he'd like he'd you know give him thumbs
up like at least trying to
you know say yeah yeah I am you know
and he also was small in stature and you
got to think about that if you got to
defecate and you have if 10 of your body
is occupied
by you know
uh Duty or whatever whatever I don't
know what you know what form it's in at
that point
or how many stages it goes through but
you got to think damn yeah that's
that's going to take up some time that's
going to take up some space it's you
know that takes up a little bit of hard
drive I think so if you don't have that
space free it makes sense kinda
you know
I mean it's hard to think if you I mean
if somebody asked me a hard question
sometimes I have to go
defecate or something for I can't even
think about it
and I don't you know
I don't think that makes me dumb or
anything but I think
it kind of makes me
you know I just gotta hedge my bets
you know I just have to give myself the
best case scenario
because it does make sense if your
body's using energy to do one thing it's
not going to have energy to do another
thing
you know that's why
I think you always got to go if you can
if there's something big coming up in
your life a wedding
uh
uh you know a birth driver's ed test
uh
uh you know gun safety or whatever
you got to defecate before you
roll in there
you know you can't be saying I do to
somebody at a wedding
when you haven't
so
see what God wants baby what else we got
some great calls that came in I want to
thank everybody that's come out to
support the show the show man the live
the tour has been really getting good
and that's been nice
um
you know tours are a little rocky when
they start out because you're out there
you're seeing what it's like in
different areas you know people want to
get out there you're trying to hedge
like what people saw last time and what
they saw so you see so it's a new show
for them so
um it's really been awesome man to get
this to get this new show really all all
tightened up and and cruising on its
legs the return of the Rat tour and
so many nice gifts one fellow brought me
this amulet
little uh religious amulet
and um
yeah we had Corey sandhagen came out in
Denver that was cool
uh the UFC gentleman and he was on here
before really
oh man real rare guy you know he's a
real
kind of stoic mental fighter he loves
you know the brain games of all of it
and
um and that was great we got to go watch
some amateur fights
and dude that was they just take a big
bar or whatever and they just turned
that they just you know there's people
damn couple bantamweights in the
bathroom just beating the
just beating the damn dry shampoo out of
each other's hair you know there's uh
it was just it was amazing it was
amazing to see some of the fights and
just the people getting out there and
doing it and I was out in Aurora
Colorado out there with uh Colorado
combat Club I think it's called
but I'm grateful to him and
um and he was out there just coaching
some guys and it was just it was awesome
it was real awesome win or lose just to
see people out there going out and
giving it they're all
all right we've had some uh calls that
have come in and sometimes they're from
you know we had uh that rail baby
big Dalton
you know he called in a couple weeks
back and
he'd been trained out you know he had
that train hit him
and you know he didn't even get a damn
ticket and he got that freak you know
that Free Ride some people you know
you know don't they're like oh look at
this bastard gets to you know don't even
have to get a ticket you know just
people want to [ __ ] about everything
but you and I know we got hit by a train
and um just powerful it was a powerful
message coming from him just hearing his
words
hearing him say hey man
I'd be willing to get hit by a train
again
because it made me have some respect for
my own life
you know a lot of with a lot of hell I'm
wandering around in life I don't even
have any respect for Life a lot of times
and I'm just wandering around in this
[ __ ]
you know that's like going to Walmart or
whatever you don't even ask what hours
they're open or closed or whatever
I don't even know that they close at 9
00 pm and it's already 5 for me
and I'm just wandering around in this
[ __ ] trying to steal some damn whatever
taffies or whatever
but that's life man it's like
you know you got to know that sometimes
it's gonna shut down
and what are you doing in the shop right
now
are you over there feeling avocados like
some damn pervert
are you learning how to do a you know do
a damn you know bake a lamb or whatever
learning something new
I don't know if I'm making any sense or
not does that make any sense Zach
that makes sense to me I get what you're
saying you're just like Dalton he's got
a new lease on life and makes you have
to slow down and think about it
I don't know if that's what I'm saying
but thank you oh sorry
um all right let's see what happened
here we had a guy some people have
called in who have also been a part of
Miracles or who've had God kind of you
know
you know touch their lip you know just
whisper into their lips
because that's really that's something
that's really honestly pretty gay dude
if I got Whispers into your mouth and
not into your ear bruh that is
you uh
you are see at that point you and that
man are probably dating each other it's
you gotta know what's going on if you're
listening to another man with your mouth
bro you already know what's good son you
got you a new little husband
um but anyway a lot of people have
experienced Miracles and so that's what
we want to get to here we want to we got
some uh a call we got a call that came
in about a man who was miracled up right
here and uh we want to see what you guys
think
what's going on the Rat King Hey Big Dog
uh my name is Julian Torres Julian
Taurus
and I'm gonna go out on a uh L
um
what is it called
LM yeah thank you I'm gonna go out on
the LM and say this guy is uh mekano
um
let's hear more
asking if
anybody has like a survival like a
Survivor story and
dude back in 2010 dude I stepped on a a
bomb lost both my legs in Afghanistan
and uh since then dude I've like kind of
Kilimanjaro dude I
um I don't know Mandy I like to think
that I'm getting after it you know
um wow
I can't
yeah I mean I can't even imagine like
you lost both of your legs
you stepped on a bomb
I mean I used to always remember when I
was a kid that thing like step on a
crack break your mother's back you know
they should have one of those for the
like step on a you know
step on or whatever lose your leg it's
kind of dumb that they teach like they
you know
but anyway man I'm talking about butt
um man unreal dude I cannot believe that
man that you don't uh
that you don't have legs anymore
and
[ __ ]
first of all bro thank you
um I'm assuming that you were in service
so thank you for your service and uh
yeah I mean
I wonder what your attitude is let's
let's hear more let's hear more
but yeah man like I see some crazy [ __ ]
uh
when I got blown up and stuff like that
man um
that seemed like um
I don't know man I'd love to tell you
the story man if you're willing to hear
I'm a huge fan and uh
I don't man I really appreciate what
you're doing for everybody man you're a
good dude and uh I look forward to
speaking to you soon
thanks bro I appreciate you I appreciate
the call man and um yeah I think I would
love to chat about it I think it's
I can't imagine what things have been
like and even if you hear certain songs
you hear that song
what is um
like a bar like uh Bombs over a bat like
if you hear that kind of [ __ ] is that
like
actually I bet you could if you're at
like a marine baller or whatever you
know you [ __ ]
you just get out there and just look you
know lose your you know
just [ __ ] pull your sword out and
just I mean you should be able to hit
some I mean if you lost your leg I'm
sure they allow you to hit somebody else
or whatever if they if you need to but
um
unreal man
or that song boom shake shake shake
I'm trying to think if there's something
that would like if something had
happened to me like that if I would get
set off you know
I should have asked even Dalton if that
song Runaway Train comes on if he you
know
wrong way on the one it's just you know
because for me a lot of things will set
me off man
um
but dude I think I would love to hear
about it man and and thanks for your
service and I can't imagine you're
sitting there your legs go like
right past you
so I'm sure your first instinct would be
to try to grab your legs
and you know
oh man I can't even imagine so I got
that means I gotta learn
um I'd love to chat about it bro
so we'll hit you up and um
and see if we can't have you on to for
the next solo episode to uh to tell us
more about that experience man and and
thank you for being brave enough just to
call and share it you know uh you know
one thing I think a lot of us have done
over the years on this podcast is share
things about us that make us feel
uncomfortable and
you know our shortcomings
um and um
and not even our shortcomings but just
our experiences that maybe sometimes
haven't been the normal experiences for
others or in some cases are but they
haven't heard other people talk about it
so they don't feel okay thinking about
it
um
but
man
I'd love to hear more
all right let's get into another call
here
what's up my name is Hector I'd love to
show just wanted to tell you a quick
story and get your opinion on it
let's hear more uh I went to family
reunion recently
and there's this email that I've never
met I wasn't aware she was Keen until
later on
we ended up talking or hit it off and
everything and then we went out in a
couple dates
ended up hitting it
and then come to find out my mom told me
she's one of my second cousins
I'm just kind of
I don't know what to think about myself
kind of
I don't feel bad because I didn't know
her but
I also don't want to enjoy it because
she's yeah let me know what you think
about that man
well brother I think this is actually a
great call that some listeners can give
feedback to you know
um
I think there's like a rule of thumb
when it comes to incest you know and uh
I don't know what it is though what's
the rule of thumb
can you Google that please that what's
the rule of thumb with incest
uh yeah I can Google that
are you talking about like what's legal
because I know some State's second
cousin is legal well I I'm pretty sure
that first
I believe First
cousin is legal
no no
second cousin
I mean
I think it depends on what browser
you're using then because they
24 States prohibit marriages between
first cousins so I'm gonna go out on a
limb you know
or is uh
yeah I'm gonna go out on a limb here
okay here we go
cousin marriage legal I'll tell you
where it's legal
Texas
California huh
Colorado
New Mexico Alaska Hawaii
Alabama Tennessee Georgia Florida New
York wow that's a really cross I mean
that cross is like political lines and
everything
my my thing is this man
here's how you know if you shouldn't
have sex with a sibling or not a sibling
but a
someone who's at well first of all
you're at a family reunion bro
maybe not a good place to
even consider sex
you know I don't know if you just you
need to wear a sign or something a
family reunion or what do you I mean
like
if you walk into a family reunion
you shouldn't walk out of there with
some chick's number bro that's crazy bro
you are I mean you're a good guy but you
also seem like you could have some
sexual predator issues
you know and I'm not judging you but I'm
just saying
every everybody else is gonna
and if you man you can't if you like
what am I what what are we saying here
Zach
I mean that was my point is if you're
going to a family reunion like what are
you was it a mistake yeah
I mean how many people are at the I
didn't have a family it's a Mexican
family reunion dude there could be it's
at a park I'm sure there could be
upwards of two to six thousand people
there I mean there's anybody getting off
a bus in La will probably stop I mean
it's
I'm sure that some of the
I'm sure there's a lot of vague
paperwork at the reunion
is all I'm saying
which is fine Felice Navidad baby you
know what I'm saying but I'm sure I
understand I think how it could happen
maybe a little bit more
if if there's a lot of people at the
reunion and Mexican people like to hang
out at the park man that [ __ ] is no joke
everybody knows it that's
they're like a part of their culture so
what does he want to know here you think
I think he's just wondering if he should
feel bad about it or not okay
um look I think it's good you're
reaching out to people because you don't
know you know what some of the laws or
bylaws are regarding you know familial
sexual contact
and uh
look I've seen people have sex that
should not be having sex
and I've seen the children of that and
that's where God really throws his two
cents in when that baby rolls out and
you're like damn you know
this thing's got you know a little extra
spine on it or something you know things
got you know
things got an extra you know it's got an
extra thumb near his ass or whatever you
know what I'm saying like that's when
you know
like damn it's but you know it's a
little buckaroo's got four rows of teeth
you know and two of them's on his
butthole you know what I'm saying that's
when you're like oh damn
shouldn't have done that
so I think you know there's a general
rule of thumb where I'm from you got to
walk at least 300 feet before you pull
your dick out
and I think that's a good rule to keep
anybody off incest or anything like that
you know
so
um
yeah and they used to say also whenever
you're about to pull your wiener out say
get away from me and then name everybody
in your family
and so that way you would make sure you
didn't have sex with somebody you
shouldn't be
so the second you break it out get away
from me Timothy get away from me Mom
Rhonda Papa
oh Christy you know Emmanuel or whatever
whoever is
then that way you're setting yourself up
for the best
but good luck out there man I would yeah
don't yeah
you know not to have sex at a family
reunion man you know it
you know what I'm saying I'm kind of
p-footing around it here you know it
you know it man
I mean I don't know what's going on in
the world where you have to call in that
people are doing sex with family
I mean how many years we have to learn
this rule
how many times do we have to learn this
rule as a society that you can't have
sex with a member of your family
because it isn't safe genetically bub
you're going to give birth to a [ __ ]
hot air balloon with legs dog
you're going to give birth to something
that's going to live in a lava lamp bub
and God don't want that and you don't
want that
you don't want to babysit a lava lamp
you don't want somebody Wheeling your
kid across and he's you know
you know and he just got a little lava
in him and he can't even he can barely
make the lava to say the words dad maybe
once a year
you don't want that
your thought
what language is that do you know
that's nothing
but it could be something
Babble can help you learn a language
it is the language learning app Babel is
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions
thanks to Babel's addictively fun and
easy bite-sized language lessons you can
finally cross learning that new language
off your list
choose from countless languages
including Spanish Italian French and
German
Babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent
whoo it's great Babble lessons were
created by over 150 language experts you
can learn in countless ways
you can learn uh with podcasting videos
games stories and even live classes
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to
babbel.com
t-h-e-o that's
b-a-v-b-e-l-.com Theo for up to 55 off
your subscription Babble language for
life I want to tell you this that uh the
best time to prepare for growth is
before growth
if you get a baby a bikini
you need to buy it for two three months
down the line
you can't get a same-day bikini on a
baby
he'll outgrow that [ __ ] in an hour
but the best time to prepare for growth
is before the opportunity arrives and
that is especially for online businesses
ship station
gets you up for growth by directly
integrating with every shopping cart and
storefront so your products are easier
to find easier to manage and easier to
get into the hands of your happy
customers
no more limiting your business to one
store ship station integrates with every
platform including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify
maximize your sales with minimal effort
98 of companies that use ship station
for one year become customers for life
join the over 130 000 companies who have
grown their e-commerce business with
ship station go to shipstation.com today
and sign up with promo code t-h-e-o for
a free 60-day trial start today and get
set up before the biggest shipping
season of the year that's two months
free visit shipstation.com Click the
microphone at the top and type in code
t-h-e-o
we got a little bit of news here let's
get into some news what um
what is this deal with the K-pop yeah
BTS they're gonna have to they're
getting drafted in South Korea because
South Korea is activating their draft
which means that the band's gonna have
to break up and these guys are gonna
have to enlist and uh
fight North Korea or whatever they're
doing
look
I believe that
I like this man
I like this because this is a real
chance for these men to become Heroes
there used to be a thing where you had
everybody had some skin in the game
you had to get if everybody was up for
potential draft
you know let me see can you look that up
Zach what the drafting was in Vietnam
that was the last draft but yeah
but before that everybody was at the you
know everybody had a chance every it was
the Hokey Pokey and everybody had one
foot in you know
that's what it was you had one foot in
the possibility to go out there and uh
support your country and put actual skin
in the game
like our boy Julian Torres did
I mean he puts he got skin in the game
and then what does it say about it Zach
yeah just that Vietnam was the last uh
draft that American men were you know
had to go in there and they did a
lottery system every day on the news
where you got if your ball was picked
and you went you know wow
so I would like to say I commend these
guys I don't know how they feel about it
I don't know how BTS feels about it
we should put BTK in there with them
whatever that guy's name was uh
Dennis reader Dennis reader Dennis
Raider Raider sent him over we should
put people you know
like that look I if I I think it would
be crazy you get a pager you're at home
I gotta go honey and you're off to war
and even the women too
a lot of women want the chance to go you
know
a lot of extreme there's a lot of
extreme women out there who want to want
equality you know exact equality and I
think that then it so then it would be
everybody has a chance to go
um
because a lot of these [ __ ] want to
wrestle bro
if I'm real honest
a lot of these [ __ ] want to wrestle
until they get in the ring
until they get over there
and there's no Balenciaga okay there's
no Activa yogurt
all right there's no uh
um
an app to get your nails done or go puff
or something like that there's no I mean
they probably have vaping
but there's none of that [ __ ] there's no
place to get your skirt hemmed you're
out there
you're hiding under a [ __ ] cactus
trying to keep you know
trying to keep your own [ __ ] legs
lady
sorry but what I'm saying is that there
is
I don't know what I'm saying dude I
[ __ ] I need got to get some help I
think
what were they asking about Zach
who
I don't know man sorry what is this
about this never mind
K-pop Superstars join white uh
look send them all in
K-pop
uh
uh a pop whoever Africa
send them in everybody
put your pop five send them [ __ ] over
there dude I think ever if they should
have all these bands fight it out to see
who's the best
that's what it's coming to anyway
you got YouTube Stars fighting it out
three years away from now
you'll have JoJo siwa fighting Leonardo
DiCaprio
for a sex change
the last sex change is going to be a new
show called The Last sex change
and they and that's how they'll do it
and the winner gets this exchanged the
loser
doesn't get their garbage picked up
anymore
it's gonna get in a [ __ ] like that
if you don't that's where it's heading
we're comp it's all going to be
competitions online DraftKings is gonna
sponsor it
you're going to be able to buy you know
you'll be you know
you'll be able to sell your legs online
if you want
what else we got Zach
um
you know this guy in New York who
releases sex tape has to be
the top of my list okay and who is he
um I'm pulling it up for you
this is a New York City Congressional
candidate Mike itkus
oh yeah he and he look right out the
gate you can tell this guy
came over to [ __ ] yes so uh he didn't
even bring his hair this guy's bringing
uh he's releasing his own sex tape to
promote a sex positive approach I guess
for political candidates I love to see
we got the first frame here
but um
I don't know do you think it'll work out
for him oh I think I mean we're talking
about it might get guess I'd vote for
this guy
uh
uh I love this I love him cutting
obviously the guy has some serious he
must have serious concerns that there's
some video about uh out there of him
having sex well apparently it says he's
focused his campaign on legalizing sex
work and ending adultery laws and
defining consent so he's just running a
sex positive campaign okay and look I
think I like this I think sometimes we
are still abiding by old rules
that don't happen anymore pull up old
laws that are outdated in some areas
you know and it you in the image here
the guy is bald-headed uh he has a suit
on he looks like the guy that gave the
Gobstopper to
um Charlie Wonka
uh uh he looks
um and he's with a sex worker and look
I've we had a sex worker on here
I think people if that's where we're at
that's where we're at
at a certain point you can't fight where
we're at
if people are you know like the guy who
Parks the cars here he does BMS 11 times
a day right I can't I I in fact he has a
his side hustle is parking the jobs his
main job is bming in here in the
bathroom
the guy is just a real
[ __ ] man
he's sitting there last time I was in
yeah and he was in there earlier when I
was in there yeah and I'll tell you what
I did
so I'm in there
and I saw he he went in behind me and I
saw him he slinks in he slinks through
quick
you know and he he's the same stall he's
one of those little same stall babies
and I respect that anybody who just goes
into a bathroom will just [ __ ] in any
stall
what
you are the serial killer of B of of
number two people
doing number twos
you'll just go in there and use any
toilet then your mother teach anything
you just say hey huh you're like that
gold the little goldilock you're just
sleeping in any bed huh you little [ __ ]
boy
but here's what I'm saying is what is
this about
um well we were you know talking about
this guy all he does is [ __ ] he doesn't
work oh yeah the valet
slash security
uh security
I'm not even getting into that oh but
here's what I noticed so I'm in there
thank you Zach I'm in there
and I see him slink past right he goes
in there and I can tell he's sitting on
the toilet
and he's waiting till he thinks I'm like
I've washed my hands he's what he thinks
I'm leaving before he does that initial
burst you know
because there's something when you go in
the bathroom and you do a BM or you do a
number two you don't want somebody here
and you make that first big pop you know
that you know when that kind of surprise
party comes out your ass when you don't
know what's gonna happen
so while I'm in there and you know what
I say I say you know what
I'm gonna [ __ ] pretend I leave so I
can hear it
and that's what I did dude
I like made like a sound like this with
my hands did the water made that open
the door let it close
[Music]
guy just drafts himself right into the
war with his own [ __ ]
right I mean just running a 50 cal bro
just parking cars all over the side of
that toilet
and then the second he did it I [ __ ]
was like
and turned on all the faucets
[ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] with me dude
you don't [ __ ] with me Whitey
or whatever that guy I think he's
actually Mexican he is
so
I'm just saying we're out here dude
and we're doing what we can what does
this lady need
what I'm saying is don't have sex with
your cousin bub
all right
what else we got what was that all about
oh it's news never mind sorry
um
Tennessee player vomits on the field
against Alabama let's see that
see how this happened in the Tennessee
Alabama game uh this guy barfed on the
field and I guess used it as an
intimidation tactic you can see him nod
oh yeah
yeah they used to do that in a lot of
the slot uh Slavic Wars a lot of uh
where is that where are the Vikings from
uh Norway
yeah cold areas a lot of that vomit it
was a ah look what I'm gonna do to you
I'm gonna digest you
also this is Tennessee somebody could
have just ordered a beer up in the
stands and that dude was trying to I
mean that's a draft
I mean that is Bush light for sure
but hey baby go big orange bro I will
say that
and there was a game a lot filled with a
lot of calls but at the end nobody was
really playing defense and um
and they won and they won
what else do we have any other good news
that came in
um we got a billion snow crabs missing
in Alaska
we got and this is what I want to talk
about the supply chain
everybody thinks that we don't have
certain things because China's not
making it
right who's the original China
Mother Nature baby
m f n mother F in
nature
the original China
the crabs are missing what do they say
huh
so uh they're estimating about a billion
snow crabs are missing from Alaska and
that's a big deal for their economy
obviously I know that people think of
like Deadliest Catch show
um but they can't find the snow crabs in
the first time in history they got to
cancel the season so the question is you
know they're potentially blaming us on
climate change they say the ice is
melting they need the ice but
I'm wondering if someone stole it yeah
you can get ice anywhere first of all
I'm gonna go put that on record
second of all I'm gonna say this
Mother Nature will change the menu guys
that's one thing people don't think you
don't you think dude two million years
ago people were having dinosaur meat a
little bit of dactyl huh a little bit of
uh of uh bronta you know oh yeah I'll
have a little bit of uh give me that
Sarah tops
um
remoulade
Mother Nature is going to change the
menu and maybe crab's gone huh
maybe [ __ ] crabs going what are you
gonna do then huh
just put you shrimp only
what about when shrimp's gone what about
when ham is gone up [ __ ]
then you're gonna [ __ ] get out of
your seat aren't you
let me tell you this mother nature will
lead us into battle with one another
when she's tired of the [ __ ]
when she's tired of the back and forth
and the [ __ ] Nicki Minaj [ __ ] or
whatever
and a lot of these fake gays people
being gay for money
and not even really being gay
people saying they're bias to sell
albums or sell calendars
I'll tell you what
you know who's bisexual [ __ ]
nature [ __ ]
and she will eat your ass with her
freaking wiener [ __ ]
because she can do whatever she wants
first she takes the crabs then she takes
the Lions then she takes the bacon
the ice is gone
what else maybe the salt
and then what are you doing huh
standing around about to [ __ ] your
family member
whatever that guy's name was Wilson
I'm just saying guys there's bigger
forces at play than we know
and you gotta you gotta you have to
recognize that at some point the gig is
up
with you just wandering around vaping
doing nothing
at some point we have to contribute to
our own Wellness
because the buffet is shutting down guys
and it's going to get sick out there
what else we got anything
uh that's a lot of the big news stories
um
yeah well there you go
sex tape advertising
accidental family sex
and uh
and that God that thing was fine oh my
God
that thing was the Halle Berry of damn
animals bro
um
if somebody
if somebody rolls up to a party with
that
I'm jealous man
um
yeah I think we covered a lot
yeah they threw Vaseline or whatever on
the van Gogh painting I saw that
and I'll tell you this is all just a big
push to get the nft business going
that's all it is
you know it's just a it's I'm sure you
got an ad the next moment for nfts
for you know Van Gogh or whatever
Lombardi
denuma whatever all you know Mona Lisa
they're all
they're all moving to nft so they're
trying to they're trying to [ __ ] you
this with the
doing that all right
that's enough
I'm tired man
there's crabs though
watch them show up somewhere and be like
now what
a billion of them is a lot
we'll see all right guys uh thank you so
much uh we'll see you guys on the next
one
um we are evolving as humans do not
forget it uh
we are not alone we have each other
um it was it was awesome to see a lot of
you guys out on the road I look forward
to seeing you uh again down the line
um
and I love you
and I hope you take care of yourselves
and uh and keep some joy in your in your
in your head space
um
you know if get some anger out of your
life you know what actually we had a
call that came in I forgot the guy had
asked about anger and we never got an
answer to him and then this call came in
and I just wanted to hear uh this
because I needed to hear this as well
when I listened to this
yo Theo this is Travis from Portland
Oregon
um what's up Travis
I mean that's something that I really
resonate with or you know have dealt
with
in my lifetime
um
and
I think one thing that's important like
everything that you said I totally
totally agree with like uh a lot of it's
just like you want to control outcomes
and when things aren't going your way
you get angry just like a little child
but I think sometimes that that little
child inside of you just needs more love
and like
you know and so something that's really
helped me
is like when when I've been angry and
upset and frustrated or whatever just
like learning to talk to myself
differently
because if you're angry with being angry
it really doesn't really get you
anywhere
um
and so
yeah just learning how to like kind of
just you know talk talk to my the part
of me that's angry like like it is my
child you know the loving Manner and
just like you know just be that
be that much mature adult you know
um for myself in those situations and
scenarios because
you know it's kind of hard to have that
that uh curve you at that
kind of in the in the Heat or whatever
yeah man that's a great that's a great
suggestion because I find that I find
when I'm angry that's what I feel like a
child
it's like a child you know
and those are the you know I still have
it even as an adult I still have those
behaviors as a child and it's hard
you know but that's a great that's a
great suggestion to really take yourself
aside and almost talk to yourself I
guess you would a child you know say hey
what's going on here you know why are
you what's happening what's really
happening
because you're not that upset about this
what's really going on
um
yeah I love that man and that just helps
you build a better relationship with
yourself and
uh and that was a great suggestion so
thank you
um and if the young man that called in
about the anger issues got to hear that
then that's uh that's perfect that's
what we're here for if you have an issue
something that's uh straining you
something you're struggling with hit the
hotline
[Music]
985-664-9503 we're gonna head out the
way that we came in
um I'm hoping to go see some Zach Bryan
uh music tomorrow night uh looking
forward to that and then I'm hoping to
be at the LSU Ole Miss game
um this weekend
oh that's gonna be a big one that's
going to be a big one uh this is Eddie
nine volt with little black
flies I love this Jam uh you guys be
good to yourself and uh
you deserve it gang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you will see the cigarette bottles on
the wall
and all the empty bottles in the hall
[Music]
don't you baby
[Music]
and I can see the way it looks in your
eyes